مشاهدينا ذكر تقرير بريطاني ان عملاء
النظام الايراني يقومون بخطف وقتل
اللاجئين السياسيين ايرانيين في تركيا
ورصد التقرير روايات من مختلف طالبي
اللجوء الايرانيين حول مؤامره النظام
الايراني ضدهم اثناء سفرهم الى مدن اخرى
في تركيا وقال عضو سابق في البحريه
الايرانيه ان عملاء النظام حاولوا خطافه
بالقرب من منزله واعتقلت الشرطه التركيه
احد عشر شخصا في هذا الصدد كما افاد
متظاهر فقد بصره بعد اصابته برصاصه في
عينه من قبل القوات القمعيه في اكتوبر
الماضي واصبح لاجئا في تركيا افاد بانه
تلقى تهديدات بالقتل من عملاء النظام
الايراني مشيرا الى انه خلال هذه الفتره
الاخيره بات يعيش سرا في تركيا وانه قطع
الاتصال بالجميع باستثناء عدد قليل من
الاشخاص موضحا انه يجب عليه مغادره تركيا
فورا لانه اصبح من السهل جدا على النظام
الايراني خطف وقتل المعارضين في تركيا